[Musique]
il y avait une super ambiance l'année
dernière nous avions gagné contre brest
ce match là était très serré et nous
avons une nouvelle fois bien joué ici et
peut-être l'année prochaine encore à
garde
[Musique]
on insiste bien sur le terme de bras de
fer sportif
pas du bras de fer de comptoir pour vos
poignets soit bien droit et beau cadeau
soit en fait je vous ayez l'épaule bien
en face que vous soyez dans l'axé médian
de la table c'est un département qui est
juste à côté de paris
variez là et en même temps c'est la
forêt c'est la campagne baptisée à tout
pour pouvoir faire du vélo le vélo des
champions comme la bicyclette en famille
tranquillement et tes amis
[Musique]
très positive
tous les bus étaient atteints pour viser
les choses de se séparer les partenaires
les collaborateurs aussi que
l'intégration
[Musique]
on est très chanceux d'avoir eu cette
fois le quart avant doublé je suis
vraiment impatient de vivre pleinement
cette expérience de mon premier roland
garros c'est génial c'est top
carter ont forcément on s'y attendait
pas forcément mais mais c'est vraiment
un super cadeau on va essayer de se
concentrer à 100% pour en tirer le
meilleur
[Musique]
victoire un peu logique et papa de
surprise pour moi psychologiquement et
physiquement je pense qu'on est un peu
mieux nos repas sur cette deuxième
partie de saison donc pas surpris disons
qu'on a bien préparé notre match et
depuis un moment et puis on les aurait
été super motivés ils voulaient
absolument la gagner
[Musique]
c'est une tradition c'est une histoire
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'histoire
de cette colline ce site
il était à l'abandon et accueil vraiment
nous notre club qui utilise aussi de
lacaune d'elancourt et quand on pense
qu'on y est il va y avoir les jeux
olympiques je pense que on a mis une
petite pierre à l'édifice pour que les
jeux soient ici quoi
[Musique]
toujours motivé à quelques jours du
départ du tour de france voilà notre
départ du championnat de france est
toujours une course spéciale donc je
suis content d'être ici pas
[Musique]
c'est génial
j'ai été proche de gagner cette année en
amérique et j'ai été ensuite à deux
coups de la victoire de francesco
molinari à what works
quand vous êtes si proche vous voulez
vraiment cette victoire
et c'est un sentiment incroyable de
l'avoir aujourd'hui net
[Musique]
la recherche du paris saint germain
aujourd'hui c'est de recréer un lien
avec l'ensemble de ses activités
sportives aujourd'hui nous sommes est
allé sur le territoire parce que ya une
histoire qui s'inscrit de cette manière
là on couvrirait la première fois que
toutes les activités sportives du paris
saint germain on voir s'implanter sur un
même lieu une semaine fantastique une
grande expérience pour tous les
spectateurs
et puis voilà en fussent à la fin c'est
l'europe qui gagne donc c'est génial on
peut parler sans qu'ils aient mis bas
oui oui ça c'est c'est c'est la fin
d'une histoire
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on s'attend toujours une
finale on aime la gagne et quand on joue
c'est parce qu'on sait qu'on dit souvent
une finale ça se gagne
là on a vraiment fait notre maximum on a
été on a été le plus haut possible et
plutôt que malheureux on est vraiment
heureux de ce de ceux de ce résultat
en tout cas de sur la saison
[Musique]
une belle répétition d'organiser
découvriront des championnats du monde
chez nous en france dans cette
installation la fédération il faire
aussi ses armes en tant qu'organisateur
[Musique]
même âge est bon on peut faire encore
quelque chose mais ne faut pas se
laisser aller
les jours on vous et soyez là vos
fauteuils et bien vous voulez plus vous
êtes foutus taïga mouais je continue
tous les jours
[Musique]
au début je croyais que c'était un rêve
qui pensait pas après quand on était sur
podium et qui a eu la marseillaise bas
ça commençait à se réaliser petit à
petit
c'est pas des bus était magique pour moi
[Musique]
malgré tout et la défaite donc l'année c
est parce qu on a abordé ce match là
pour par le remporter on n'a pas
remporté ce match mais je tiens à saluer
le courage l'abnégation et le coeur que
mes joueurs ont mis sur ce match